be absolutely perfect to get to not get a deduction of 0.1 so it's not uncommon
to let's say there's 20 steps and you made let's say 15 mistakes so what would
that be so we'll leave that there on this side and we'll come back and we'll
just calculate the score at the end so major mistake say you're supposed to
turn to the left when you turn to the right that would be a major mistake so
obviously we do want to try to avoid any of these major mistakes so after we
done our pattern that's when we move on to the presentation side so the
presentation as you can see it's from a score of six this six is actually split
up into three parts so we have one two three here so with this one for a score
of two is your power and speed your rhythm is also a score of two and your
expression of energy is also a score of two
as well so we'll start off with the power and speed so with this one whether
it's your blocks your kicks your strikes your punches anything you are that you
do you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well so that it's one
thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be both
strong and fast to get high in that in that category the next part is your
rhythm so the rhythm when you do start your pattern there is a rhythm to the
pattern it's not just really fast all the way through it's not slow all the
way through there's a slow fast slow fast kind of aspect to it as well so you
do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also scored out of the two
the last bit is your expression of energy so what is expression of energy
so that's basically how loud you shout so how much intensity you have during
your pattern as well so so you're doing your pattern really well it's really
fast and it's strong
is really great but you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the
judges can kind of tell you're not really confident you're a little bit
nervous so that's why we need to kind of improve on as well. So I'll just come around to this side so with this one for
color belts and black belts it's actually scored a little bit differently
so if you're a color belt you'll actually your average so where where the
judges actually mark you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your
average so say you did alright you did average compared to everyone else your score for 1, 2 and 3 it'll start from a 1.1 so if you're less than average in the judges
eyes you might go down to say for your power and speed you might get a 1 or even
a 0.9 if you did really great you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4
you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4
so each individual category you need to obviously get as high as you can if
you're a black belt generally depending on the competition you will be scored
from a 1.3 so a 1.3 would be your average that you start from so say
your power and speed was above average average you might get scored a 1.4
let's say 1.4 for now say your rhythm was only about
average
it wasn't amazing it might be just a 1.3 but let's say you didn't shout very
loud so your expression of energy your average was 1.3 it might drop to say
let's say a 1.0 so with this one we'll come over down to this side so with this
one as I was saying it's a total of our 10 so that's it and for presentation we
had 1.7 1 2 3 so you added 3.7 let's say you made 15 mistakes so with this one
obviously don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes
this is with the judges we have three judges usually at the panel and each
judge obviously it's very subjective so from their point of view you might have
made a lot of mistakes or you may have made a lot of mistakes
not a lot of mistakes as well so that's why we have the three judges and we
average it out as well okay so say we did our 15 mistakes very small mistakes
so if they're all minus 0.1 you'd be 1.5 so you go 4.0 minus 1.5 which equals 2.5
so this would be your accuracy score so with our presentation like this
before we're saying we've got a 3.7 here so we add these numbers at the after the
judges are finished scoring so you would get for this pattern a 6.2 which is
actually very good so I'll just talk about a little bit more now about this
number here so if you're a color belt if you're a yellow or above and you do your
patterns it's not uncommon generally for a color belt
the average is about a 4 to 5 so if you get a number between four and five out
of ten for your pattern that's actually generally considered pretty good so
anything above that you can consider yourself pretty good if you're a black
belt the average would say because we're talking here about the higher
presentation as an average anything from five to
sorry five to six
five to six
is actually considered pretty pretty good and anything over a seven is actually considered
almost world class so if you get a seven for any of your patterns you generally need to pat
yourself on the back you did an amazing job so we just went through our form day scoring
so just remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation is a 6.0 accuracy is judged during your pattern
presentation is after and then we get two scores that we add up and we get that number so with
this one obviously say I was I was judge number one I would give you a 6.2 there was another
judge on the other side maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did so maybe this one would
be a little bit lower it might be a five point something another judge on the other side they
scored a little bit higher so we get three numbers and then we average that
as well so I hope this helped you guys so make sure you enjoy your pool day competitions and
anytime I make sure obviously you record down your numbers as well so this is minor errors
while you're watching your video I can just then major errors
and then right after the performance you can rate yourself power and speed coordination
expression of energy we cannot pause the video this time you're gonna be rating yourself as a
judge without pauses okay so we can real time see your video and rate yourself
as a judge so I hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see you guys in the next one bye
bye
Okay, I'm going to do space.
All right.
Does it mean specifically?